bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
time well while she's trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get a
lunch money right we've got big news
today you guys wanted to see me dressed
like Polina there you go I got the
profile shirt on planner writes a daily
newsletter read the profile calm go
check it out every Sunday what do we
have in the news today so remember that
bill I was telling you about the 484
billion dollar bill you were you tell us
about better than we read that on the
Internet
on Tuesday um when the Senate is today
Friday today's Friday
yeah when the Senate passed it and now
the House passed it and so now Trump
just us to sign it in it's for 84
billion to go to small businesses and
hospitals do you think he's gonna sign
it yes all right so 484 billion dollars
the new stimulus has now been approved
to President Trump today at 12:00 noon
eastern kind of like when once am I
supposed to come out well known he's
feeling our rush stick there he's gonna
sign this bill important because 310
billion dollars will go to replenish the
paycheck protection program I've been
calling it the payroll protection
program but I think is actually a
paycheck you know I make mistakes every
once in a while so 310 billion dollars
will go to replenish that they had 350
billion they ran out of money
here's another 310 billion 60 billion of
it will go into the disaster fund it's
basically a alone bucket where people
can go when there is issues and disaster
60 billion for that there is 25 billion
if I remember friendly yeah 25 billion
is gonna go to coronavirus testing which
is obviously really important and then
75 billion dollars is going to go to
hospitals to help them be overrun with
the corona virus do you want to know my
favorite part about this do i yeah the
hospital's seventy five billion dollars
a lot of people don't understand the
economics in the hospital and all of
their high marks and revenue disappeared
because there's no elective surgeries
going on all that and most emergency
room visits right my
Jason was explaining to me most of their
emergency room visits is actually very
thin margins or actually a loss leader
so they're either losing money or not
making a lot of money and that's
exploded so they have an incredible
economic pressure right now so
thankfully they're getting some help got
seventy five billion dollars in the
stimulus so for the 60 billion that's
going to the Small Business
Administration does that mean that small
businesses have to apply again so
there's 360 370 billion sixty billion
goes into a relief it's like a disaster
relief I forget the name of it
and then there is 310 billion that will
go into the paycheck protection program
so the 310 billion if you already have a
phone application yeah then users are
still waiting now you can start to tap
into some of those funds once this is
signed and I believe that you have to
apply for the disaster loans but if
you've already applied I'm sure that you
can then just get you know access to it
you're basically like just waiting in
line okay but it's not gonna cover
everybody who applied absolutely not
that three hundred fifty billion dollars
that they already gave the first time
only covers like three to four percent
of all the applications so another three
hundred ten billion let's say that we
get lucky and it gets us to ten percent
of everyone who applied right now what's
not known is how many of the people who
applied are like the shake Shack's and
you know all of these companies that
maybe don't actually need it as a small
business so that's unknown but I don't
think 310 billion no it's gonna be
enough and they're already talking about
the next stimulus package so what ends
up being kind of annoying to me is they
approved one they ran out of money it
took them a week last end of last week
is when they ran out of money it took an
entire week to get another package put
together voted on approved right and now
they're gonna get it signed this Friday
or today so if this happens again that
means there'll be another week gap from
when they run out of money till when he
gets actually improves why don't you
just like approve all the money of
course well that's what they said the
Federal Reserve already said they have
unlimited money but the thing is who's
going to who would be in favor of voting
for let's say five trillion dollar
stimulus package Oh 10 trillion is me
it's just more palatable palatable by
the way the palpations if you watch
yesterday's episode I said that word
our patient we found out later maybe
that wasn't the right word but you know
I'm allowed to make two mistakes in one
episode that's fine yeah did you know
that I was making a mistake yeah I told
you you want me do you want me to say
that you were right yes okay what's the
next topic here draftkings drafting went
public at a time when there are no life
sports to bet on what do you think about
that
let me quench my thirst real anyway can
I just say that the cup that he is using
to drink water this is from my my
blender hey big talkers gotta have a big
cup of water you know it's fine
so draftkings they're going public today
look this makes a lot of sense first of
all they're doing through a reverse
merger if I remember correctly so
they're not doing the traditional IPO
listing a second of all draftkings and
FanDuel tried to merge a couple years
ago didn't work out so draftkings that
one alone and yes there are new life
sports right now but basically you've
got to make a bet like do you think life
sports are coming back I think it most
people well the business is I see what
you're pulling that thread you're
bullying on there but draftkings whole
business model is to allow people to bet
on live sports right and so if you want
to invest in this business then
obviously you've got to have an
underlying belief that last course will
come back I think that they will and
let's not forget there's still table
tennis if you guys want to bet on life
sports maybe we can live stream our
chess and backgammon I destroy her in
chest
it's literally like call the police it's
a crime scene the bat game is not a real
game it's mall over Lucknow match at
chess is a game of skill intelligence
and I destroy you I think that I'd beat
you so many times that when you hear the
word chess it and you're sleeping
you have nightmares okay let's talk
about dinner bunny what's going on with
dinner yeah and who won the game though
cards that you can buy to your favorite
restaurants to support them is that
right yeah so restaurants under
incredible pressure most of them shut
down
cash flow because they don't have strong
balance sheets so what a lot of them
have done is I think 232 Bleecker in New
York City was the first one to do it and
they basically sell it almost like a
gift card hey buy a meal now and you can
come in and redeem this in the future
okay but it gives us cash flow today can
I just ask you okay so for in this form
still in July a lot of these restaurants
are going to be long gone how am I gonna
redeem my gift card to a restaurant that
doesn't exist anymore
my guess is the reason why they're
calling it bonds is because you can lose
money on a blog oh so like you
technically could if the restaurant
doesn't come back like I guess you could
just lose the money I'd have to look to
be sure but I'm guessing that's why they
call it that and then I really liked in
Europe there was a group they came up
and they called it the war bonds right
they really like we're at war against
the virus like by one of our war bonds
it's the same thing it's still a dinner
bond but it's just really cool to see
kind of American and international
entrepreneurs come up with very creative
and innovative ways to drive cash flow
and try to survive during the crisis
would you buy one yeah so for example
one restaurant is selling $80 bonds with
$100 redemption value so I guess the way
it grows and value is like you go and
you're a demon frog yeah you get it do
you know what kind of return that would
be 25 five you're saying Richard nice I
didn't meet her I didn't either put on
the spot to do some math real quick all
right Jack Dorsey what's up with with
Jack the og okay so first of all there's
a deep profile on Jack Dorsey and Vanity
Fair it's very interesting it talks
about basically he has like a crazy
morning ritual do you know what salt
juices before we get to that Vanity Fair
I thought that that was like a clothing
company is that that's a media company
Wow interesting
okay all right keep going what are you
asking me do you know what salt juices
I'm assuming it's juice with salt in it
I'm not a scientist but no it's what he
drinks he calls it eating which is a
little strange but it's basically salt
water and lemon and then he doesn't eat
anything I'm told it so it's lemon juice
salt aerosol
so it is juice with salt I was right no
I'm not a scientist but hey all right so
what what is the point of this the point
is there's a really good profile in him
if you want to read it it's in Vanity
Fair and which is a media company not a
clothing cut another thing he did is
partnered with Beyonce to donate six
million dollars in relief for a central
workers on the front lines at the
coronavirus Jackson og because I think
we were talking about on what he's
drinking so he doesn't eat food before
dinner he goes the entire day without
eating he just drinks this drink that
she described and then he drink a lot of
water and stuff the other thing I think
he does doesn't he walk to work and
walking to work is like a number of
miles yeah he does yeah I think he does
that his life so he's just very much
into like kind of meditation I think
he's very much into what was it called
when you you go long periods of time
without eating starvation no not
starvation intermittent fasting
intermittent yeah whatever is fine okay
so and then he donated six million
dollars with Beyonce who do you think
put more money in equal what's your
favorite Beyonce story story yeah mine
is when she when she did the performance
at uber and took equity rather than took
cash and got millions of dollars in
equity in uber and it'd be worth a
couple hundred she performed their
Christmas party and she took it in
equity instead of cash um pay me in
equity that's in a song what my favorite
memory is we went for my birthday two
years ago last year sometime not good no
- um the Beyonce comes are you okay do
some of my water you need some lemon
juice and salt okay that would be
illegal that's literally a salty
coronavirus conscient the Beyonce jay-z
concert and he wouldn't you love the
Beyonce portion of it that's your story
yeah all right speaking of performances
Travis Scott Travis Scott by the way
Netflix documentary on Travis Scott I
Levi can fly I think is what is called
is fantastic my favorite part is in the
documentary he's performing on a stage
in front of literally like 12 people at
like a State Fair and he's going you
know ham on stage he's rapping he's got
all the beats and everything and there's
12 people there and they all are just
like yeah who's this dude yeah okay
who's this guy
and then they fast-forward in like
within three years he's literally sold
out mega arenas and he's going nuts
doing the exact same thing he was doing
at the State Fair but now he's doing in
front of you know tens of thousands of
people and so last night he did what he
I don't know he had a concert inside of
a fortnight so inside of the game
he held a massive concert so it's inside
of the game right and basically wouldn't
have happened does it say how many
people actually showed up to watch it
it's really really cool maybe well we'll
put a link in the in the description of
the video later 10 million people showed
up now that was marshmallow though
there's another concert previously
marshmallow did a concert we're ten
million people I don't know how many
people showed up to a Travis Scott but
we'll put a link in the description it's
super super cool to see how they're
using all of the gaming kind of graphics
and everything inside a fortnight and
then the beauty is obviously it's almost
like a virtual concert so millions of
people around the world can all tune in
at the same time okay so I've heard
about this idea of virtual concerts and
whatever but like wouldn't I just go
pull up Justin Beiber YouTube videos and
watch it yeah but what but what wouldn't
you want to watch the thing that's
happening live like why do you watch the
VMAs to watch the performances when I
watch them okay why do you watch the
Oscars these Oscars movies or music
movies whatever whatever the other one
is most the other of the music won the
Grammys do you watch the Grammys yes why
oh because I think I know more actors
that I do singers all right so long
story short if this is gonna be huge I
actually think that this is good like
they're gonna continue to do this more
and more because what remember the fan
understands is the fame the musician
gets a bigger audience by doing it
virtually rather than in person yeah now
there is something to be said about like
I'm gonna go to Madison Square Garden
there's an artist there like I get the
experience but would you rather hit 10
million people or would you rather go to
Madison Square Garden sellout you know
30 40 thousand that's true this is gonna
this is gonna really change the way we
experience live events I think are you
ready for VR world like will you put on
the goggles and go into the VR world
have you seen ready player one no no do
you want to watch it no all right we'll
report back to you guys on Monday all
right any anything else before we get
into lunch money no are you sure yeah
you have no parting thoughts are you mad
about anything today we all got the
expect you guys finally got to see the
wrath of Polina I deal with that on a
daily basis no but I was just passionate
I wasn't I agree I thought you had great
ideas thank you I'm always supportive
all right lunch money while Wall Street
is trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
which means this weekend we're picking
one winner hundred bucks to give to you
what you have to do to win the $100 or
to be eligible for winning if take the
URL of any episode that is your favorite
okay or that taking the URL of this
episode okay she wins take the URL of
any episode tweet it or post it to
social media use the hashtag lunch money
you have to use the hashtag lunch money
so we can find it and tell us what is
the one thing that you have learned this
week from lunch money our whole goal
with this is one to make you guys laugh
to poke fun at Wall Street while they're
trying to get rich the rest of us just
try to get some lunch money but also to
make sure that people are staying on top
of current events
learning and hopefully expanding their
knowledge so take the URL go tweet it or
post on social media use the hashtag
lunch money we'll pick one person
hundred bucks you can go buy some lunch
you can go buy some dinner bonds you can
go donate it you can go put it on black
on draftkings do whatever you want but
you'll get a hundred bucks for for
sharing it you know what I learned what
this week what did you learn I learned
that it's not Scottie pee Scottie Pippen
Scottie Pippen I look funny I don't like
Travis Scott
sun-hee your Scottie Pippen oh my god I
think that we've reached this level of
quarantine where she's literally got me
wearing her shirts actually this is for
sure it's my shirt but her logo on it
what did I learn yeah I learned that we
were gonna keep the laughing gas away
from you because that laughing attack I
think I'm gonna have nightmares about it
because that was absurd
I was worried about your help I thought
we were gonna have to go to the
emergency room it was just going yeah of
course I'm afraid you can't face me you
could beat me up you could shoot me you
could literally have a laughing attack
you could pass out like I'm gonna keep
serving the people serve the people we
serve people alright guys that's it for
lunch money this week well while she's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get a lunch money right
everyday nude ish before afternoon right
at noon or 5:00 p.m. depend on if we got
our [ __ ] together or not we appreciate
you guys watching leave a comment we try
to go through and read all of them and
comment back Polina
literally is tired at 10:50 in the
morning and we will pick one winner for
a hundred bucks
go take the URL tweet it post on social
media use hash tag lunch money tell us
what you learned this week and we will
tell you on Monday who wins the hundred
dollars that's it see ya